pouvez-vous m'entendre quelqu'un fils de la
terre paquebot Galileo crash Mayday
code d'urgence sept quatre un cinq
c'est Daisy farad comme le manoir de
deuxième classe Earthship Galileo nous nous sommes
écrasés et nous avons besoin d'aide
alors quel est le plan de sécurité avez-vous
vu quelqu'un  sinon tu as quelque chose à
dire s'il te plaît qu'est-ce que tu es une infirmière
détail de la sécurité non ils ne m'ont pas préparé pour les
dinosaures dans la formation de base juste de gros
lézards
[Musique]
vidéo anéantie toute danse
ce qui s'est passé protocole de pureté en signe de
danger et le  mission ça a frappé
[Musique]
si les dinosaures assoiffés de sang ne vous suffisaient pas